But, uh, yeah,
let's talk about some current topics that don't just nostalgic trips back to
high school.
Talk about high school and so much, but I'm gonna still be funny stories. Yeah.
It's, it's the prologue to our life memories, people listening.
So this was still in high school, went understand,
but once you're out of high school, you'll understand. You'll look back on them.
You sound like such a grandpa saying that you'll look back to your high school
one day back in the day when we only had three I-phones no, but,
um, what's the, I guess the big news,
of course, everyone's your news by the time this episode everyone's loving that,
but I guess like some news that is more industry driven is the whole,
uh Funimation and crunch roll thing. Right?
So Sony buying out, crunchy roll,
basically having a control of like most of the big anime companies just
monopolize the Western market.
It is, it is slightly worrying from an off when you hear that,
initially that's a lot of market share that Sony has. Yeah.
Like how would, at what point would it be considered a Sony? Like,
I guess from a monopoly, if they had like Netflix,
I feel like if they had crunch.
Roll Funimation and Netflix, then, then it would be like, then it,
then it would be like 99% basically.
Cause basically I think the only other company is probably since I film works
who do high dive and they're still going, I know it's still going.
Sorry, sorry. I guess just.
Not available outside the U S right? So it's.
No it's available in the UK as well. Yeah. I didn't know that, but I, I,
the problem with high dive is that I don't know how many big,
like exclusive titles that they have. I mean, how can you compete?
Cause the only, the only thing that I've watched,
like the only big exclusive I've watched off high dive is probably legend of the
galactic heroes. And that's like, that's like old, old,
like the old,
they're the only service that have licensed the OJI legend of neglect to kill a
while. And I feel like,
I don't know other how many other exclusives they have outside of that?
I never used high dose. Cause I know it made him the best.
I watched that on Amazon strike
Amazon strike. If Amazon stopped buying it.
Cause like, I don't know what anime they've got getting anymore.
The problem with Amazon is that they buy one big show.
They want like last year they had bill and saga.
But the big problem with it Amazon is that they sometimes get big shows,
but I've done other marketing.
I hate like watching anime on Amazon because they,
I don't know what shows they have half the time.
They actually have quite a lot of anime,
but nobody knows about this because nobody work. Just anime on Amazon. Yeah.
Not to mention that.
I think the general problem with Amazon is that they don't know how to market
it. Like you find out usually second-hand from someone who's like, Oh,
I watch soccer on Amazon.
And you just like Finland soccer is Amazon. What the? I mean, Amazon is Finland.
Yeah. Like actually watching it isn't bad.
Like the players are really good and I don't know like what conversion they're
using, but like, man, it looks Christmas. Yeah. But God.
Is it horrible to use their platform? Holy dude. I'm like, am I renting the?
Or am I streaming it? That's clear half the time. I didn't mean to rent bar at,
why am I, why am I watching? I try to watch anime. What the? Amazon.
And then also, because now obviously we're using,
I'm using Amazon prime in Japan. Yeah. Amazon did that pro game.
A move of being like, um, yeah,
no subtitles for other languages outside of this country.
So if I want to watch it, I have to buy prime,
which I have in Japan and prime in the UK or the U S, which is just stupid.
It's probably even worse for you here. Like UK prime work for you here. No,
you couldn't do that because it doesn't work for me. No, no. You need to use,
you have prime, but it's really Japanese prime. It doesn't offer any English.
Subtitles. Yeah. And obviously, because they're like,
we don't want people going on to other countries and buying stuff,
which kind of makes sense. But also why, like, who cares? Like,
like it's 20, 20, I dunno why licensing laws.
Haven't caught up to the fact that the it's a global media rail.
If you're not going to, if you, if you're going to limit it to one country,
people are going to find a way to, you know,
find other ways to watch it because people are going to watch it.
Whatever happens. Like most people like,
cause I keep these threads on like on Reddit where I like, bro,
if you buy Netflix now in Turkey, you can get it for like $2. And I'm like,
but that seems like a lot of, like really calf that much.
I'm glad that if I put all that effort in, I can save a whole $4. Yeah.
You got to keep using a VPN when you logged in and do that anyway.
So you already paid for the VPN anyway and it's like, it's not worth the effort,
man. Like, do I really need this? No, I don't. Who cares? Like, I'll just,
I just want it in the country that I'm in.
I don't wanna have to around with VPNs. Don't make this hard for me. Yeah.
And Amazon, obviously you made it. They're like, how about,
how do we make it as hard as possible every single day?
How do we make it so that you accidentally buy a instead of watching villain?
Sorry. That's basically like the Amazon prime experience. Do we have any like,
I guess,
cause there is very little information about the whole like Sony acquisition.
All right. Yeah. I mean it's, it's still very early days now mainly.
And how much was it for how much was because we don't know.
Innovation buying or Sony buying cultivation or Sony buying credit.
So Sony,
when they bought 95% of Funimation in 2017,
it was around 143 million.
That's right. That did do that. 43 for Funimation.
Crunchy roll it's around 1.2 billion.
Wasn't Amazon only like 900 million number again. One,
1.1 $0.2 billion. Gigi,
Gigi crush shuttle. That's more Amazon bought.
Twitch switch for Jesus Christ. Wow. Oh my God.
The question that I want to know for Funimation yeah. That's already surprising,
but like the, the biggest question I have is like, it's like, all right, cool.
You have all this money, right. To spend on crunch, roll in front of nation.
That's fine. But in my opinion, it's just like,
what are you going to do with it? Is the question. I mean,
I guess because when Sony back in the day bought the 95% of Funimation or
whatever, it was like, mm, not gonna lie. They didn't,
they didn't really do much with it. Yeah.
I haven't seen much of a change from Funimation. I like,
I don't know how well Funimation was doing back then,
but it seems like they've just gone, gone on business as usual.
Now 1.2 billion for crunch,
or just kind of sees how much they're investing in anime, I guess.
And because they must see the potential in the anime industry to get to
like chill out this big,
I guess maybe they're willing to throw that much money because they realized
that there is a massive competitive now, and that is Netflix. Yeah.
Yeah. I mean,
I guess when you put it into perspective of like Twitch was bought out,
but that was like how many years ago was Twitch bought out by.
Like 20? Probably around the same time that Sonny first bought Funimation. Yeah.
No, it was earlier than that. I think it was like 2016, right?
It must've happened 2015. Really? Yeah. But still can you Google it? Yeah.
2001. Twitch was like the big back then.
Yeah. So Twitch was 970 million.
We just switched to 2014. I understand.
You only make sense of Twitch nowadays pretty worth like five, six times easily.
Yeah.
Yeah. But that was, I would say that, you know, getting to that point,
comparing Crunchyroll now to Twitch back then, which is still bigger.
I would say, I would say like Twitch was like a hot property.
Cause everyone was expecting YouTube by Twitch.
I remember back in the day where we hit, like where it was just like, yeah,
everyone, just, everyone was like, well, Google was going to buy it too.
Which that just, that's just a natural move. Right.
And it was a big surprise when Amazon kind of, [inaudible].
Been great for creators there, but like, yeah, but that happened,
but I'm curious as to why. Um, do you have any thoughts of my wife?
This might be good or bad for anime fans?
I mean, I'd say as a consumer,
it would probably be better because okay. For money.
In the, in the industry is always better. It's.
Not only that, but I remember,
I would say like the golden age of like anime streaming was,
remember when you could get every anime you could conceivably want to watch on
one platform, which was crunchy roll back in the day.
And then it kind of just like got spread out to, you know,
different streaming companies.
And that was inevitable that it was going to inevitably. But I,
the biggest thing I find annoying, isn't the,
isn't just the fact that I have to pay for like different streaming companies.
It's just the fact that nowadays when I see, when I go through the,
when I go through an anime char I literally have no idea which anime is going to
be on which platform. Yeah, that's true. I was,
this specifically says like prime example. Like I just, like,
I just want to like log onto one service and be like, okay, I just want to,
I don't care how much I'm paying for this service.
I just wouldn't want it to one.
I just want to watch all the anime want to watch it at one service.
It's like confusing because I thought, ah [inaudible]
. Is that correct? Yeah. It was on Netflix. No, that was on crunchy crunch, but
it is on Netflix. Is it in Japan? No. In Japan. In Japan, it's really confusing living in Japan.
Cause I'm like, wait, who owns? What? Because Japan like, because
obviously it's pretty much Japan rest of
the world. That's how it works. Right. Obviously. And it was really confusing. So I'm like,
wait, wait, where do I watch it though? I realize Netflix doesn't offer English
sometimes, probably for that reason too. The
licensing, right? Yeah. It's a mess. It is a mess
. It's like, how do I, how do I know what the I'm watching? And then everyone's just laughing being like, ha
ha piracy. You know, like, yeah. I mean, I want to pay, I want an easy service.
I mean, I, I want a convenience service.
Like I am willing to pay for a convenience service,
which for the longest time it was until it wasn't. And now it's like,
I, you know, I want to support the industry, but at the same time,
it's just like, if, if I'm having trouble finding which service has got,
which anime, like I literally have two lists. There,
there is a dedicated search engine for this, which is like,
I think the name is like, because Maui or something,
that's the name of the website, right?
That's literally a dedicated search engine to search which anime is,
is on which streaming. So someone had to make that.
It's like, there's, pre-owned uh, like, like a spreadsheet,
like pre-order to know what's on what me.
Say then in that instance that I guess like a full monopoly of the
Western market onto one service is a benefit.
I mean, it's not the no, not monopoly though, is it really.
Right? But that's what I'm saying though. Like if, for example, he's always bad.
Yeah. But that's what I'm saying. But for example, if Sony,
hypothetically is like, Hey,
we want to like buy the anime side of things from the Netflix's thing. Right.
That would truly, I would say turn it into a monopoly.
At least in terms of the West.
Basically be at no monopoly, that'd be awful for the anime fan.
So it would be all for anime fans. But.
Same logic they gone was saying it would all be on one platform too.
I mean that, that's kind of like the kind of like the Disney argument now,
isn't it like, yes. All my characters now are going to be in the MCU.
Yay. For monopoly right here, you know?
Right. It's like with, with the whole Disney,
it's worrying because if everything's on Disney,
we only get Disney esque products. Right. I don't want Disney. I hate this.
Remind me of, uh, the other day when I was streaming,
I don't know how true this is. So take this with a grain of salt.
But somebody was saying that there's a rumor that Disney might be acquiring
Sean and jump. Oh my God. No, no, no. Seriously.
I don't know how true that is. Back. Check this mailing. Please. Can you,
can you fact check this check?
Because he sounded pretty convincing when someone like people in the chat were
talking about it,
but apparently Disney is thinking to acquire it because they want to do a
collaborative thing between my hero, academia and MCU.
No.
And I'm just in my head outside. That's gotta be a troll. If it is a troll, then
if it is a troll, then I fallen for the bait. But at the same time,
I wouldn't be surprised if Disney actually won.
I do. I cannot stand it.
Well, because like, think about it. It's like MCU, super heroes. My hero,
super heroes. It's a match made in heaven according to Disney. Right.
Bro. I can't wait for when life, all my, it shows up in Avengers.
Five was I'm like, you don't see it.
[inaudible].
Do you know what that would mean though? The like Thanos versus Goku means like
I'm gonna come. Like you won't be horrible for like a realistic standpoint,
but my God
and memes that would come out of this will be up again.
Like take it with a grain of salt. It might be a troll. It might be,
I might be talking out of my. I don't know.
That just means like every MCU conversation would, would end with both.
Goku could be a Coke and could be captain America.